welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of
daredevil season one previously a
netflix production but now joining the
marvel titles on disney plus as charlie
cox matt murdock and vincent d'onofrio
wilson fisk have officially made their
way into other mcu titles and while
charlie cox's spider-man no way home
screening may not have given him his
proper due that's not how we reacted
we must revisit these 13 episodes not
just to understand how this hero will
fit into a broader universe of
characters but to appreciate the
overlooked details and deeper layer of
meaning of this full amazing storyline
so let's go
this video was sponsored by our friends
at heroes journal more on them later
starting with episode 1 into the ring we
opened on matt's father jack murdock
arriving on the accident that exposed
matt to chemicals that blinded him young
matt is played by skylar gertner who
went on to play jonah on ozark jack's
face is the last thing that matt sees as
his vision corrodes like photography
film in an acid bath just like this
neighborhood will rot under organized
crime the fact that the last time matt
sees this block it's sunny and still
mostly uncorrupted leaves him with that
idealism that keeps him biting but the
liquid that blinds matt was a direct
inspiration for the liquid bleeding over
the landmarks of hell's kitchen in the
series beautiful opening credits
according to patrick claire who is head
of the design team that made it they
considered the insidious corruption
creeping into the city with its
reconstruction efforts after the
avengers battle to be linked with the
same liquid that poisoned matt and all
of its bloody and visceral as it does in
this imagery nothing in hell's kitchen
is left unstained by this blood in
confession with father lantum matt
describes his father's boxing days yeah
guys he went up against used to say i
was like hitting oak he's foretelling
his own fighting style taught to him by
another piece of wood stick he goes on
his eyes would go dead he'd start
walking forward real slow hands at his
sides like he wasn't afraid of anything
yes this is matt's aspiration a fighter
with inactive eyes but a man without
fear slowly marching up to his
combatants with his hands down as we see
matt do in the hallway in episode 2 but
he's confessing not for since he has
committed but for what he is about to do
what is that stopping a human
trafficking deal between turk barrett
and the russians matt's wearing a
pre-daredevil outfit inspired by frank
miller's man without fear run we meet
foggy nelson and brett mahoney and matt
and foggy tore new office space this
office was barely touched by the
incident which is why it's on the market
already the neighbors weren't so lucky
the uh incident is that what we're
calling it now well it sounds so much
better than death and destruction
raining from the sky nearly wiping
hell's kitchen off the map ah yes the
first of many references in all of these
series to the battle of new york in the
avengers yeah the world watched half of
new york get destroyed
that's a lot of sympathy heroes and
their consequences are why
we have our current opportunities now
this series was a production of marvel
television a separate division of marvel
than kevin feige's marvel studios
however now that charlie cox matt
murdock has been formally established in
the mcu continuity there is enough
interconnectivity from the daredevil
side of the mcu to establish that at
least some of this narrative if not all
of it to be official mcu cannon karen
page gets framed for murder as part of
the corruption by her employer union
allied who is embezzling construction
funds after the battle of new york now
the wilson fisk we see in hawkeye was
active around that time in a deleted
scene we saw meeting with eleanor bishop
in 2012 and he was seen as the uncle
boss of the tracksuit mafia even earlier
in 2007 now the tracksuits do not come
up in the series but there are various
russian gangs that wilson is in the mix
with matt's apartment always has windows
lit from the outside at night time by
these bright signs giving his windows
this multi-colored glow almost like the
stained glass of a church like every
moment of his life he is back in that
confessional booth however now he is a
priest taking the confession from karen
because as he interviews her like before
we see her reflected in his glasses but
this time she is reflected in both
lenses she lies but cannot escape his
perception the other criminal leaders
meet including leland owsley madame gao
nobu vladimir and anatoly ronskehov they
meet with fisk's right-hand man wesley
gao and nobu are of course later
revealed to be critical associates of
the hand owlsley meanwhile in the comics
is a mob boss called the owl madame gao
uses blind drug packagers like matt just
more victims blinded by the toxic crime
of this world their heroine is stamped
with a symbol of the steel serpent in
the serious continuity the name of their
organization but in the comics is the
name of the alias of the iron fest
villain in davos and we get our final
shot of this episode
making the episode closing as it began
with the sun crying out for his father
matt's father did not want his son to
end up in the ring like him but now
father matt doesn't want another kid to
get bloodied up but episode 2 cut man
opens with our sliced up vigilante's
blood all over the asphalt dripping from
the dumpster a realized version of the
opening credits blood everywhere but
setting up the amazing final sequence is
really a rematch to this unseen beating
we meet claire temple who says i'll call
you mike mike yeah a guy used to date
turns out he was very good at keeping
secrets too could be a reference to mike
murdock the bs twin brother identity
that matt made up in the comics in order
to throw off karen and foggy and
spider-man a flashback shows young matt
wincing at the bell
so when roscoe and silk tell jack i
heard about the wee one that's a tough
break you have our condolences you're
young yet plenty of time to have more
kids matt totally heard them say that
from across the room he actually
flinches like this later this episode
waking it to the gunshot that kills his
dad for refusing to take a dive that
planned dive was in a rematch with
crusher creel aka the absorbing man from
the comics he's actually a major
character in agents of shield also among
these match-up posters on the walls is
one that mentions barton which could be
an odd to clint barton though hawkeye
hasn't really been known to be a boxer
though in season three there is one for
parker versus morales peter parker
versus miles morales so they just like
to put marvel names on these walls in
josie's bar foggy points out how the
patriots are all good-hearted neighbors
we are this close to getting his kids
into saint agnes daycare say magnus yes
saint agnes is the orphanage where matt
lived after his dad died also an agent's
shield where daisy spent her youth the
episode ends with the most famous shot
of the series a five and a half minute
long take showing matt beating those
russian kidnappers in this hallway
leading to the long tradition in the
netflix defender's universe of hallway
fights but what makes this great isn't
simply the fact that it's just a long
take actually every time the camera
passes over that fallen door there is a
hidden cut on the pan and to be honest
it's becoming a bit of an old hat when
directors do these long takes for no
reason other than to show off but in
this case it is totally worth it because
it makes us feel matt's exhaustion as he
fights each thug and struggles to get
back up catching his breath and you only
feel that if it unfolds in real time and
by the way this is at the end of a night
where matt already almost died several
times we know how tired this guy is and
like in real fights when guys get hit
they don't stay down here it's really a
war of attrition until the other side is
just too exhausted to fight on and
there's just a ton of little flourishes
that i love like we do not initially see
what leads to the door falling down just
a guy crashing down through it and we're
surprised when that happens and then as
that second guy walks into the doorway
he's totally blindsided by a microwave
that matt if you think about it must
have thrown as he heard that guy
stepping down the hallway and then when
matt wrestles the gun out of their hands
he does not shoot them with it he just
uses it as a blood instrument to beat
them with the sound mixing also plays a
huge role in the sequence like when it
opens we hear the buzz of fluorescent
bulbs
and then throughout a flurry of hits and
grunts and music especially important
when characters go off screen but only
when he beats that last guy does the
buzzing return
[Music]
matt lifts his mask because he knows the
kid seeing a fatherly face is the one
way he's gonna reassure the scare kid
and if you think about it it is the last
thing he saw with his own eyes that
reassured him and as they exit matt
steps on that tipped door that we have
passed over several times already but
now listen
yes the door finally cracks signaling
matt's completion here and symbolizing
the door he just broke down to the
city's worst criminal threats episode 3
rabbit in a snowstorm matt follows
wesley by listening to his watch and the
frame blurs everything around where
matt's focusing and it is on this suv
where we get our first shot of wilson
fisk but seen only by his cufflinks
which is how hawkeye first teased the
character upon seeing fisk's car matt
notices his bleeding through his shirt
from the night before almost as if the
sighting of fisk alone was enough to
draw first blood between the two across
the hall from nelson and murdoch's
office is a company called atlas
investments a nod to atlas comics atlas
being the original name of the company
that became marvel also on foggy's door
is the previous tenant van lunt maybe a
nod to cornelius van lent the marvel
villain taurus in the office of ben
yurick a past new york bulletin reads
battle of new york another reference to
the events of the avengers another reads
harlem terror referencing the brawl with
abomination in the incredible hulk in
this episode nelson and murdock score a
legal victory for healy who's still not
a good guy so matt's able to get his
boss's name from him fesk
wilson fisk but since healy spoke the
name he offs himself yikes couldn't
couldn't you just move now this
episode's title gets spoken by vanessa
in the final scene when she and we meet
fisk there's an old children's joke you
hold up a white piece of paper and you
ask
what's this a rabbit in a snowstorm fisk
responds it makes me feel alone because
as the invisible man behind the curtain
of this city's underworld a guy often
clad in white he feels isolated in a
storm no one else can see a man now
framed in this white painting
contrasting the man in black who now
knows his name episode 4 in the blood
wesley shames the russian brothers about
getting beaten up by the man in black i
mean if he had an iron suit or a magic
hammer maybe that would explain why you
keep getting your asses handed to you of
course reverend scene iron man and thor
the brother is talking to their wounded
buddy
yes given us how matt gained the moniker
of the devil of hell's kitchen which is
first seen in print in episode seven the
next time fisk meets vanessa at the
gallery notice she now wears white as if
expecting him to come back and wearing
his favorite color but not realizing
she's really just gonna become part of
his snowstorm i really like the choice
of this series to introduce fisk as a
romantic delaying his violence in order
to imbue him with the softness of the
necessities in him similar to the choice
in hawkeye to introduce him as the
paternal uncle figure to maya lopez the
russians kidnap claire and matt opens
the window to listen to the city but
notice he has to control his own
breathing and his heartbeat to quiet
himself first before the sounds of the
city can come in
uric cautions karen don't visit me at
the office anymore
and don't tell anyone else about this
that doesn't work for you get up and get
the hell out of my life yes and in that
moment police lights flicker on her face
as she agrees foreshadowing the guilt
she will be left with when uric dies
into looking into this as wesley takes
anatoly to fisk he says this interesting
line they say the past is etched in
stone but it isn't it's smoke trapped in
a closed room swirling
changing buffeted by the passing of
years and wishful thinking but even
though our perception of it changes one
thing remains constant the past can
never be completely erased it lingers
like the scent of burning wood i just
love how this is true both for fisk and
murdoch two men who reflect on their
pasts not as dried ink to read and learn
from but really as changeable narratives
that they're willing to shift in order
to best serve whatever their present
fights are and at the end of the episode
fisk's violent core finally explodes you
embarrassed me embarrassed me in front
of her
yikes this points to his body armor seen
under his torn suit and says dumb mr
potter i'll need a new suit referring to
melvin potter aka gladiator in the
comics the armorer of these series hooks
up fisk and later matt with their suits
now an important distinction here while
wilson fisk is extremely violent and
very strong his invulnerability on these
series comes from him wearing body armor
whereas in hawkeye he didn't seem to be
wearing body armor and he seemed to have
more supernatural strength though who
knows in the mcu that could come from
like a super soldier serum dose we'll
see i suppose episode 5 world on fire
matt explains to claire how he perceives
the world i guess you have to think of
it as more than just five senses i can't
see not like everyone else but i can
feel things like uh balance the
direction micro changes in air density
vibrations blankets of
temperature variations mix all that with
what i hear
subtle smells all of the fragments form
a sort of impressionistic painting okay
but what does that look like what do you
actually see a world on fire matt uses
the metaphor of an impressionistic
painting another parallel between him
and fisk who felt alone in the snowstorm
of the white painting ice versus fire we
get another long take in this episode
two minutes swiveling inside of the
russian taxi we actually swivel past
matt kind of like a slasher villain
there and then we swivel back to show
he's gone this whole car interior camera
rotation long take was used by alfonso
coron and children of men and also in an
episode of hawkeye when matt sits at the
police station behind him is a poster
that reads you don't have to reveal your
identity to help solve violent crime
exactly his mo as a masked vigilante
taking the law in his own hands and
behind mahoney at the desk on the right
side stan lee cameos as a celebrated
police officer in one of the photos
getting the answers to these questions
is quite a quest for me yes i feel like
i'm on my own campbellian heroes journey
and in my own life i like to document my
progress by staging it this way and an
awesome new thing to help me do that is
hero's journal hero's journal is here to
help you accomplish your goals by
turning them into a quest the hero's
journal helps you discover the story you
tell about yourself and define the quest
you want to undertake they have two
different journals the istoria magic
academy for fans of harry potter and the
legend of astoria for folks more aligned
with lord of the rings and they have a
special new leather edition of the
journal made from vegan leather the
adventurers edition it's got fancy
foiling on the spine a lovely green
cloth ribbon that would just be a really
great gift to get someone whatever your
goals involve the heroes journal guides
you along the journey to achieving them
by building a positive narrative about
productivity versus a shame based
narrative you can try the first 71 pages
of the journal for free online if you
want to check it out that way but the
hero's journal is available for purchase
now head to
theheroesjournal.co or click the link in
the description and use promo code new
rockstars for your 10 off and thanks
again to heroes journal for sponsoring
this video vanessa tells fisk about a
past lover all of a sudden this tall man
in a white suit and
ascot mascot that's a bit much yes this
is the white suit that fisk later dawns
on the regular and he explains its
vision for the city rebuilding this city
i want to carve something beautiful out
of its ugliness
set free its potential yeah i love how
he uses the word carve like a sculptor
does but also the way a killer does he
fidgets again with his father's cuff
links something he did when he went back
to the gallery to ask vanessa out and he
says that he wears these to remember his
father which is presented here as a kind
of a sweet thing but as we see later
they remind him of how he killed his
father fisk knows there is a gun in
vanessa's purse which might have been
something he noticed when she first
walked up earlier holding her purse with
two hands and when she set it down extra
carefully as she sat madame gao hits the
russians with the suicide bomber leaving
matt with his metaphorical world on fire
now literalized a fire that ends the
dinner dates both of foggy and karen and
of fisk and vanessa because no one can
live peacefully in a world on fire
episode six condemned a title that both
describes matt's situation on the run
from the cops in the aftermath of the
bombing of hell's kitchen and the
literal condemned building that he and
vladimir hole up in when other media
show up in the area one of the vans is
whih the mcu in universe news service
meanwhile one of the new york one hosts
is real life host pat kiernan
technically the first on-screen talent
to appear both in marvel studios titles
and the netflix ones as we've seen him
as a recurring news presence in hawkeye
and far from home and no way home
there's actually his voice speaking the
opening words of that movie the shocking
video was released earlier today fisk
has a sniper shoot detective blake a
sniper who carries with them in ace of
spades which was thought to be a nod to
bullseye before ben point extra bullseye
joined the series in season three
episode seven stick matt's old mentor
stick is brought in to help matt had
seen agnes what about the mother is she
dead oh no she's
well that's another story matt's mother
maggie suffered from various mental
health struggles throughout her life and
later became a nun as sister margaret in
the park stick teaches young matt to
perceive the hungry dog the woman in
love the old man is actually dying and
matt folds his ice cream rapper in the
scene showing how he's already making
that friendship bracelet that he later
gives his stick which stick hates
but we actually later learned that he
kept it all that time oh matt helps
stick intercept nobu's shipment a crate
translating to asano robotics a
subsidiary of the roxanne corporation
the mcu energy conglomerate and the
company behind the roxcart town of haven
hills and loki and also the name asano
is an odd to yoshida asano aka samurai
steel an iron man villain black sky is
revealed to be a child as we learn in
season two the hand worships black sky
as a mystical figure that a lecturer
comes to embody when stick later reveals
he killed the kid he and matt fight and
matt eventually subdues him by doing his
favorite spin kick move that he actually
used to finish off the hallway fight in
episode two and stick says you can keep
the sticks
you're gonna need him leaving matt with
the metaphorical pieces of himself
critical tools that matt will use to
assemble his gear at the end of this
episode we see stick talking with stone
a fellow member of the chaste in the
comics stone is stick's pupil and both
of them battle the hand but i don't
think we see stone come back yet on to
episode 8 shadows in the glass bisk
wakes up from a nightmare to find
himself in another nightmare his rabbit
in a snowstorm but this is a nightmare
that he controls yo-yo ma's cello music
plays over his morning routine first a
close-up of a knife on sheathing again
carving something beautiful as we see
his finery his drawer of cufflinks a
life he carved from something unrefined
revealed in his shadow in the glass his
blood-soaked younger self i like how
they cheated this reflection being in
the same room by initially avoiding
showing the wall with the mirror as fisk
first walks into the closet back in
wilson's youth in the 70s we see him
carving again in this case sawing to
help his dad's campaign signs you caught
it too short yes wilson absorbs all his
father's bad advice down to a fear of
half measures bill ends this scene by
hammering a nail into his own head on
the poster foreshadowing his own death
another flashback wilson's mom serves
him the zupa that he ordered for himself
and vanessa like how he tries to restage
his one healthy female relationship now
with vanessa a relationship that
actually isn't really that healthy we
later learned his true draw to the
painting the scratched paint on the wall
that he had to stare at while his father
abused his mother reminding him of that
night that he killed his father and
inherited his father's violent nature
but he also inherited his mother's icy
resolve get the saw yes the same tool
that wilson tried to use to build up the
city he now has to use to clean up his
first obstacle to that goal now the
third time wilson wakes up to see the
painting on the wall there's no yo-yo
mod cello because now he wakes up with
vanessa by his side and now when he
turns to look at his closet mirror it's
not himself but vanessa blocking his
reflection his shadows and glass are now
buried so he can reclaim his father's
mission to lead the city episode 9 speak
of the devil father landon tells matt
how he used to think the concept of the
devil was propaganda by the church to
condense all adversarial evils into one
superstition ah jokes on him mephisto is
real he thought that way until a rwandan
warlord murdered a beloved elder and
that man who took tahiti's life i saw
the devil so yes
matthew i believe he walks among us
taking many forms and for matt the devil
will take the forms of fisk of nobu the
hand but also to answer lance's question
of how to defeat them matt will himself
have to become the devil even lucifer
was once an angel uric meets with nelson
and murdoch friend of yours came to see
me the other night the man in the mask
terrorist cop killer says he was framed
yeah i could say i'm captain america but
he doesn't put wings on my head boggy
references the classic wing design on
captain america's helmet something that
the designs of the mcu have really
reduced and rendered to be angular easy
to overlook matt tells vanessa i'm told
by my guest my apartment's a bit stark
yeah probably not intentional but in
iron man 2 tony stark did get rid of all
of his paintings and now here in this
year of 2015 stark just recently vacated
avengers tower so the wordplay kind of
tracks now one thing i love about this
episode is how it wisely breaks up matt
and nobu's duel into vignettes
throughout the episode because it is so
brutal with nobu's koketsu shoge that
unlike the hallway fight this is really
best consumed in measured doses matt
wins by knocking that blade into the
lamp sparks igniting the chemicals on
nobu giving this devil his world on fire
so don't worry nobu comes back episode
10 nelson vs murdoch which features
foggy nelson learning the truth about
matt murdock and becoming a huge whiner
for the rest of the series in one scene
fisk meets gao in the rockefeller
rooftop gardens a location also known
for the first spider-man and she warns
him man cannot be both
savior and oppressor light and shadow
one has to be sacrifice for the other
choose and choose wisely or others
shall choose for you yeah this season is
really an origin story for both matt
murdock and wilson fisk both transformed
from hiding who they are to really
owning it and a flashback to their law
school days foggy asks are you trying to
tell me that you didn't take spanish to
snuggle up to what's her name the greek
girl would i surely i would take greek
she was taking spanish sure he spoke
greek whatever happened to her she was
smoking ah man it didn't work out yes of
course referring to alexa nachios matt's
flame whom we meet in season two a
flashback shows their old law firm not
only does my client roxanne energy
corporation categorically deny any
culpability in your diagnosis yes
another nod to roxanne the mcu's energy
conglomerate who really just screws over
everyone throughout the history of the
mcu now throughout matt's confession to
foggy this episode notice how he speaks
to him with his glasses off it's one of
the few scenes this season he ever does
this showing how for right now at least
he's gone from a man taking others
confessions to giving his own because he
also took off his glasses when he
confessed to father lantern in the first
episode nelson murdoch's former tenant
van lunt comes back up again i didn't
vote for senator to last election a few
people did very still one said it was
because of the advice he got from van
lunt and his cracked pot astrologer you
can believe that
yeah he's the guy who
owns this mausoleum yes cornelius van
nunt again as taurus a guy who dresses
up as a minotaur likely would have been
into astrological signs onto episode 11
the path of the righteous matt learns
from turk barrett the location of melvin
potter's workshop filled with
interesting easter eggs as he walks in
on that design table is fabric with a
diamond logo this is the logo of one of
the gladiators looks from the comics
which he actually later wears in season
three there's also a poster reading
gladiatores another gladiator reference
you can also see some telescopic leg
armor a nod to daredevil villain stilt
man and then at one point he throws a
buzz saw at matt and not to him getting
buzz saw arms in the comics blueprints
for which actually show up in episode
13. at the end of this episode karen
grabs a gun from wesley do you really
think
i would put a loaded gun on the table
where you could reach it i don't know
do you really think this is the first
time i've shot someone this page
yes in season three we learned that
karen sold drugs in vermont and her
boyfriend todd got in a fight with her
brother kevin tried to burn down todd's
house and to keep todd away she shot
todd in the shoulder before she was
driving and gotten a wreck that ended up
killing kevin that's her dark past
episode 12 the ones we leave behind
opens with karen's nightmare of wilson
fist confronting her about taking that
life it gets easier the more you do it
but the irony is bisque has been waking
up gasping for air as well and that for
him has gotten easier the more he does
it matt and your chat about gals blind
men nobody look at a blind man twice
no i wouldn't yes like uric's life when
he said the vigilante sounds like a
boxer just another hint that uric likely
deduced his secret as he does in the
comics after getting sacked when europe
brings his stuff home we get a clearer
look at his battle of new york cover and
it shows a crashed chatari leviathan on
the buildings of manhattan and this
appears in the shadows of uric's
apartment just as he did in karen's
nightmare i like how on the shelf to the
right of this who's the book titled the
power broker as he really secretly is as
the kingpin of the city it's not sharon
carter and tragically fisk murders euric
begins to the finale episode 13
daredevil leland reveals his betrayal to
fisk and as they brawl leland tries to
tase him in the head but it has little
effect compared to when he tastes matt
earlier this season and it flattened him
as this episode resolves hoffman spills
the beans in parvati's nesendorma plays
over the fbi arrest montage godfather
style we see the rest of turk barrett as
well as the daily bulletin editor who
gave yurik that odd look in the previous
episode when he accused ellison of being
bought off interesting little twist
there also marcy's boss and state
senator cherry and then wilson fisk
himself who to his arresting officer
cites the parable of the good samaritan
and i'm not the samaritan then i'm not
the priest or the levite that i am the
ill intent who set upon the traveler on
a road that he should not have been on i
always liked how this parallel jewels
monologue and pulp fiction as he tried
to cast himself as the righteous man or
the tyranny of evil men or the shepherd
in ezekiel 25 17. while wilson fisk here
casts himself as the true biblical evil
jules does accept his role but leaves
room for faith truth is you're the weak
and i am the tyranny of evil men but i'm
trying ringo i'm trying real
hard to be the shepherd and then matt
now wearing his new daredevil suit from
potter fights fisk in an alley but more
than physical duel it really is a turf
war spoken between these two men i
wanted to make this city something
better
than it is
something beautiful you took that away
from me
you took everything and then after the
first round of this fight this true
spite comes to the
surface city
doesn't deserve a better tomorrow he
deserves to travel and it smells it
deserves people like my father people
like you and fisk finally revealing that
he does not actually believe in the city
that is what allows matt to finally
retake the moral high ground and reclaim
his turf this is my city
my family
newspaper dubs him daredevil finally
spoke in this series if you look closely
at that article senator sherry's quote
says i have done nothing wrong and
neither has mr fisk even facing jail
time he still fears fisk enough to not
testify against him an indicator to us
that wilson fisk is still a powerful
threat in this world this ends the
season finally wearing white just a
white prisoner jumpsuit but the rabbit
is still in the snowstorm as he finds a
new scratch surface to glare at
everywhere this man looks madness as you
can see this was a great season on
television with plenty of interesting
mcu tie-ins and a lot of groundwork for
marvel studios to just adopt a lot of
this as true mcu canon you can support
new rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eafos
following rockstars subscribe to the
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you